welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and star wars the clone wars final
season gave even greater depth to the
heartbreak of Revenge of the Sith with
animated faces somehow saving more human
than real ones
now that season 7 has ended I'm gonna go
back through each episode for all the
interesting Star Wars Easter eggs
timeline updates indie missable details
that really made the prequels better how
do we do this for the sequel trilogy no
kidding I would never want to turn back
time on being able to do a video called
Palpatine the whole Clone Wars series is
about the relationship between Anakin
Skywalker and ahsoka tano ahsoka it's a
friend whose journey truly motivates
Anakin to part with the Jedi motivation
deeper than love or mommy issues
motivation based on defiant
individualism the first of all episodes
are the bad batch arc reanimated
versions of the story reels released in
2015
experimental unit clone falls 99 the
defective clones with the desirable
mutations 99 a nice touch their name 99
is a nod to the beloved janitor clone 99
who Oakley died during the past season
attack on Kamino
whole idea is to humanize the clone
troopers to make their betrayal of the
Jedi under order 66 emotionally
devastating this patch includes hunter
tech crosshair and wrecker hunters
helmet it looks like an early prototype
for the later Imperial stormtrooper
helmet on their ship is a poster
translating to clone history month
Geonosis showing respect for the first
wave of clone troopers who fought on
Geonosis there are our best signs and
posters everywhere I'll just kind of
review the more interesting ones this
first episode also shows fire NOx
lurking in the background those are the
sunlight devotee predators that also
show up in rebels and actually exempt on
a couple droids you know what's going on
maybe it's another branch actually the
same stormtrooper banter in a new hope
on the Death Star
I know what's going on
so to edit a new scene with Padme
visibly prego even though this would be
set before she reveals to Anakin and
Revenge of the Sith that she's pregnant
Padme is wearing a similar outfit that
she wears later on Mustafar so seems
like the idea is to remind us of this
coming breakup and make us feel feels
but more importantly we learned that
obi-wan knew about this affair I hope
you at least told Padme I said hello
so this recontextualize is their affair
to be more of a poorly kept secret which
makes Obi one less naive and a true
friend to Anakin for not writing them
out they did remove this very real bit
with the sexy Padme art on the side of
their ship but that art does show up in
the background of rebels they got it in
on this [ __ ] with the rescue echo long
thought to be dead since season 3 but
actually plugged into a separatist
computer to counter the clones movements
echos drama and pale part cybernetic
body give Anakin a look at his own
future the dark destiny hinted at by
that final exchange between that go and
Rex yeah just like old times
in this episode Tech's goggles scroll
through some or abbess translating to
Star Wars creatures we've met before
bones ami neck sue Toydarian Peka Peka
Peugeot me Bray and wampa and Anakin
takes down the separatist droid the same
way destroys a droid right before he
meets ahsoka in the movie one of the
many echoes linking these two even
though we don't see them together most
of these episodes this arc ends with
Anakin's dark step toward destiny
killing Admiral trench this time for
real jool Jedi
I don't have to squeeze the Imperial
March played a bit there and when he
kills trench the Emperor's theme plays
[Music]
okay on to the Martez arc included to
show how common folk actually hate the
Jedi he'll be justify society turning on
him after order 66 after leaving the
Jedi ahsoka meets trace and Rafa Marquez
and the lower levels of course haunt you
happen to crash onto one of the best
repair shops on 13 13 13 13 is a nod to
this setting being inspired by the
cancelled boba fett video game 1313
Sokka knocks the radar dish off a
cruiser not to the running gag with the
Millennium Falcon and throughout the
background of this art or sighting to
the races of the occupants of the Maz
Eisley cantina and a new hope many of
these sightings dressed in their rare
original action figure clothes Rhodian
Ithorian diff Twi'lek aqua licious erase
the Ponda Baba some loathe cats also
appear originally from the animated
series but a live-action version showed
up in the Mandalorian a sign in the
laundromat translates to Calrissian soap
Rafa has some gambling debts suggesting
that she might have already crossed
paths with or one day might well-known
gambler Lando Calrissian in this episode
they fix binary load lifters which
actually was the first gig c-3po
mentions having a new hope in the next
episode when they pass the Republic
fleet
Anakin senses ahsoka he's with Admiral
yularen here who's aged up to bring him
closer to his appearance in a new hope
and a consenting her parallels a similar
moment when he will sense his son and
return the Jedi they add to the spice
mines of Kessel which also showed up in
solo store story and they end up dumping
their shipments as Han Solo claims to
have done when he makes excuses to
Greedo even I get boarded sometimes do
you think I had a choice so she says I'm
taking us a fortune and glory which is a
nod to Harrison Ford's other scoundrel
character fortune and glory kid
fortune and glory sisters revealed their
family died during the past pursuit of
zero the hut and Rafa alludes to
Luminara Unduli the Jedi whom ahsoka was
close with and whose padawan led to the
wrongful accusation the resulted in
ahsoka leaving the order
bo Catan returns the Mandalorian and
sister to Satine
with her is Ursa Ren mother to Sabine
Wren and rebels one theory is that that
mysterious female armor for the
Mandalorian could be an older version of
mocha tan or another from this night
owls group Marquez's meet with Tunes the
same race as poor old ben quadinaros
from been two minutes their supervisors
at Rand ocean-like Bosque the bounty
hunter or the bounty hunters in the
Mandalorian notice when Rafa kicks him
the Sam Department mixes in a raptor
Yelp from Jurassic Park the Pikes meet
with Maul mentions his new crime
organization the opportunity to take
control of your operation ah this ties
together mauls criminal scheming from
the shadow collective in the animated
series to the name of his operation in
the live-action solo picking of all this
brings us to the amazing final arc opens
with the lucas own title card and the
Series title in red which is how they
introduce small episodes and past we are
now right before the events of Revenge
of the Sith we see the Jedi meeting
include a team of Abha
and her apprentice caleb dume who will
later grew up to be kanan jarrus and
rebels khyati moody's there along with
plot kun and Aayla Secura we find out
they've been deployed to outer rim
planets to meet Grievous is offensive
which is all part of Palpatine's plan to
scatter the more experienced jedi away
from the core planets in order to lead
the Jedi Temple less defended and again
it tricks the droids with a fake
surrender and notice the tense music
it's similar to the music when his son
Luke will trick Jabba with a fake
surrender and Return of the Jedi so it
is with these thoughts in mind that I
gladly surrender myself to the
[Music]
oby wants now got a few more gray hairs
as he doesn't revenge of the set and he
saves Commander Cody's life which you
know hurts knowing that Cody will betray
him
soon after this and also yeah obligated
the point of the Akbar reference here
it's a trap you fools
they learned of a call from Anakin's
fulcrum subspace frequency which they
first think is Sagar era our old buddy
from Alderaan system who via appears in
rogue one but it is actually a soca
which confirms to us that her later
fulcrum spy codename and rebels it was
also used by characters like hessian and
or was a name inspired by her friendship
with Anakin ahsoka walks off the
transport ramp into force theme plays
[Music]
fuku-san asked for help to retake
Mandalore from Maul bringing up Obi
Wan's past relationship with her sister
Satine my sister I thought she meant
something to you but I cannot allow my
feelings to cloud my judgment okay
anakin who absolutely let his romantic
feelings cloud his judgment kind of his
whole thing and again tells us Sokka
loyalty means everything to close
technically yes since it's their
programs loyalty to the Republic and
Palpatine that cuts through their
emotional ties to us so can the other
Jedi
Rex shows how the members of the 501st
have painted there how much do look like
a Sokka which I know I'm sorry it's just
a weird thing to do I look past your
face it's on my face but yes of course
it sets up the series amazing final shot
so I gotta give us some love look before
we keep going we've been working real
hard to keep breaking this stuff down
but full disclosure guys it's been tough
new rock stars was already a skeleton
crew of five and now we're afraid to say
the word skeleton you might not know
this but during this crisis this
platform has been additionally
penalizing creators stiffing hard-earned
views with pennies on the dollar of ad
revenue we're fighting to stay afloat
however we can we've been trying some
all business government loans but
they've been endlessly delayed it seems
so our last hope has been to partner
with other small businesses who are just
trying to help us all get through this
too one thing I have been needing help
with its findings freaking hand
sanitizer he's insane markups by online
retailers it's super frustrating
thankfully we were able to partner with
another small business called sanitize
and chill sanitize and chill combines
hospital-grade ethanol-based hand
sanitizer with CBD which has been great
helping me with things like my
inflammation no worries we have been
checking up on this ourselves because we
did not want to get behind any product
that wasn't gonna be actually effective
at killing viruses and we have had
third-party medical professionals weigh
in we're able to meet the highest levels
of guidelines so this is it there is no
THC in this stuff so you're not gonna
get high but your hands will get clean
which is what we need the green color is
because there's actually a lot of aloe
vera in this stuff it helps keep your
hand smooth each bottle has 100
milligrams of CBD an alcohol content of
the sanitizer is above the 60% level
that the CDC recommends for inactivating
the viruses and we're all worried about
this says 70% alcohol it's stronger than
those brands that we took for granted
that no longer on the shelves now there
is a limited supply of 2,500 bottles
because of the small
the company and the quality of the
product so go check it out if you can go
for the multi bottle bundle packs
because there's seriously discounted it
so if you're looking for a hand
sanitizer and if you want to help us out
act now go to bitly comm slash and our
chill and use the code new rockstars
tenets check out for 10 percent off your
order and again folks this is just new
rockstars doing her best to stay afloat
during these troubled times so if you're
interested in doing this thank you for
the help so much obi-wan informs them
that the Battle of course ant has begun
what about the Chancellor Shakti has
been sent to protect him but Master
Windu is lost contact with them this is
a nod to the deleted scene from Revenge
of the Sith and which Grievous kills the
Jedi Shakti they decided to split the
fiber chip first with Rex commanding the
new unit the 332nd explaining how the PI
puncher first end up with Anakin when he
led them into the Jedi Temple kill that
little kid Anakin gives us Sokka two
lightsabers and they see each other's
flesh faces for the last time yeah you
could definitely see the dread in a
sokka's eyes almost as if she knows the
next time they see each other will be
when he's Vader and rebels they
descended to Mandalore
ahsoka is echoing anakin from their very
first mission rushed to the top i give
me a head style and the music that plays
during the sequence is the same as the
opening music and Revenge of the Sith as
Anakin engages in a parallel crash
landing which is occurring concurrently
with this one so this is the two mission
following episode episode 10 that they
had some apprentice is the seasons pest
its title refers to malls revealed with
Sokka that Anakin is the future
apprentice to the titular Phantom Menace
a Palpatine Sidious he has long been
groomed for he's wrong my mouse does new
apprentice obi-wan says he's on his way
to you too pal
it tells us okay that Anakin is now
spying on pal between for the Jedi
Council observe you mean spy music again
is the Emperor's theme and based on the
timeline we are now about halfway
through Revenge of the Sith
after obi-wan and Anakin had parted as
friends Olmec dies revealing whom all
really wanted here this guy
Hey just like yonas vinyl words also the
music that plays are the high octave
notes from the Imperial March the same
instrumentation that played over Vader's
dying breaths in Return of the Jedi
[Music]
Mall meets with reps from the syndicate
to go into hiding including the Pyke's
black son in this dude which I think we
can assume is dryden boss from solo
malls of crimson dawn lieutenant mall
rallies his troopers you once liberated
me from my imprisonment by Sidious there
just not the way of your people to hide
here in my gutters well living
underground and gutters will be the way
for future Mandalorians of course this
group customized their armor to purflex
malls appearance and this is the group
that actually saved mall in the son of
Dathomir comics storyline which you
should read because it bridges the gap
between malls captured by Sidious in
season 5 int his return here mall also
customized the throne room with red and
black banners and he lifts in chokes
polka tan at the same place and manner
that he did to her sister Satine so
cruel Amal tells us oka that Sidious is
behind this whole plot is behind
everything
shadows o mirror a male as later words
about Sidious and the rise of Skywalker
so pop the teens been out there all this
time pulling the strings mom gives us
okay the same join me spiel that Vader
gives Luke and Tyler gives Rey everyone
does this and of course it turns into a
thrilling duel with the fight
choreography animated from motion
capture by Laura Mary Kim and original
Darth Maul actor himself Rey Park reason
why this fight is so fluid it's because
Rey Park moves so fast that the
animators had trouble keeping up with
him he ignites his dual-wield saber
these same way as he did in the Phantom
Menace so sick he also later elbows
ahsoka to the face just like he did to
qui gonn before he gave his killing blow
and yeah the music of this fight
incorporates choir to just like be John
Williams do love dates malls vinyl rant
is chilling burning includes Anakin left
burnt and scarred by the fateful duel
that he will wage shortly after this in
the timeline and the next episode opens
by restating the Jedi conference from
Revenge of the Sith showing how Rex and
ahsoka were actually part of it I sense
a plot to destroy this
great care we must take
a sense of plot to destroy the Jedi
great care we must I gotta give some
love to composer Kevin Kiner in these
final episodes he did some amazing work
[Music]
these hunting sip tones evoke Vangelis
is famous score from Blade Runner
molls Hannibal style confinement is in
an alluring relic from their past wars
with the Jedi on it is engraved an
ancient Mandalorian saber wielder I'm
diggin could beat our vizla the
Mandalorian Jedi who forged and wielded
the dark saber ahsoka tells Rex we were
trained to be keepers of the Peace not
soldiers this same line was spoken by
mace windu in attack of the clones with
keepers of the Peace not soldiers and
yeah it's a good point why are these
people fighting the war it's a big
mistake Maul and ahsoka hear voices
ringing out of terror from Anakin's
betrayal of Windu yeah this audio was
resampled from Revenge of the Sith
except Anakin's water have I done which
was re-recorded by the Clone Wars Anakin
voice Matt Lanter Sidious gives order 66
to Rex this his eyes dilated signaling
this order hijacking his mind but Rex
trembles as he tries to resist it fine
music playing here is Anakin's dark
deeds which played over Anakin's
massacre-killing that kid
fives was Rex's bud he died after
discovering the inhibitor chip
conspiracy that moment was the seed that
later allows Rex to momentarily resist
here ahsoka boots up a few astromechs
including our seven in a new one ch3
three-peat voiced by Dave Luna himself
the screen shows tip lar whose death by
tup led to Phibes investigating the
inhibitor chips try Anakin's pass code
eight one zero eight a passcode could be
a nod to Clone Wars premiere year 2008
and hey beer wall marches down the
hallway similar to Vader's Death March
in Row one he smashes one of the ceiling
pulls their blasters out of their hands
he forces them to flee by blast doors
meanwhile ahsoka locates Rex's chip with
a familiar chant
I am one with the floors and the forces
with me yes this is the old mantra of
chert and way in row one on one with the
force the force is with me cheer it was
not a Jedi but a more devout force
practitioner like ahsoka who no longer
lines with a Jedi Order but still
connects with the spirituality of the
force
Rex confirms the dark truth the entire
Grand Army of the Republic has been
ordered to hunt down and destroy the
Jedi Knights like that nod to obi-wan
with the voices crying out in terror
line here's another nod to the old man
who described this tragic history to
Luke the Empire hunt down and destroy
the Jedi Knights
the final episode is titled victory and
death a nod to the chant of maules
followers in the son of Dathomir comic
indeed Baal is the victor who manages to
escape this mess well that's okay kinda
it's too bad I don't think she feels too
victorious ahsoka and Rex set their
blasters to stun his final season uses
stun in a few times actually it's a
throwback to these stun used on Leia in
a new hope rarely ever after Rick's and
so could get through it with the classic
Star Wars I got me a prisoner move the
problem is ahsoka tano is no longer a
Jedi hasn't been for some time this has
been the justification for how a Sokka
survived order 66 and semantically how
she's still alive to the upcoming season
of the Mandalorian despite Yoda Tony
Lucca returned the Jedi ahsoka tries to
keep them all from escaping similar to
Rey restraint in departing craft in the
rise of Skywalker but ahsoka let's Maul
escape to save her friend she does the
right thing because I'm like race she's
not the product of Palpatine Orden his
clones - I don't care actually the ship
that Maul escapes in is the same model
of the ship that we first saw
ahsoka arriving in the Clone Wars movie
so many memories the final six minutes
of the series are dialogue free just
pure beautiful visual storytelling
ahsoka and Rex bury the clone troopers
who just tried to kill them both the
332nd and others it doesn't matter
because as a series has shown us all
clone troopers have an inner humanity
their graves with their helmets is a
heartbreaking reflection of these
stormtrooper heads on Tatooine in the
Mandalorian and we settle on Jesse's
helmet emblazoned with the Republic
crest symbolizing the death of the
Republic that they once served through
the end forever loyal even when it
betrayed them to pave way for the rise
of the Empire
ahsoka drops the saber
and we dissolved to sometime months or
years later when the sabre is recovered
by the friend who gave it to her now
must assume she's among these fallen the
last piece of his soul ripped away from
him which gives us so much more meaning
to his later discovery of her and rebels
as we learn in the force awakens
lightsabers sometimes contain memories
of their past wielders so by wielding it
here
igniting themself in the blue glow
Anakin is trying to connect with ahsoka
a hint that goodness in him may live on
through his eyepiece it can actually see
something we've never been able to see
through Vader's mask the eye of the man
underneath above a condor bird flies his
most likely morai
the spirit animal bird that ahsoka
revealed in rebels a piece of the force
deity the daughter when her spirit was
channeled into ahsoka what Vader takes
away from this who knows all we know is
he simply turns and leaves he shrinks in
the eyepiece of the ahsoka helmet
linking the three forces of the series
in one image the face of ahsoka Anakin
in the troopers who fought alongside
them I like to think the shot is
thematically parallel to the final shot
of the Phantom apprentice this is all
about ahsoka peering out from a divide
she's trying to connect with her friend
but she knows deep down that that friend
is gone he's left her alone in the cold
ku dose to Dave Filoni in the whole team
I can't wait to see where they go next
with ahsoka in the Mandalorian season to
follow me on Instagram and Twitter a TA
vos holo new rock stars and subscribe to
this channel for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]